he is back here on the Rich Eisen show
thrilled to have Mike doc Emmerich how
are you doc I'm good and share has been
in a lot of NHL rinks this spring about
the same time the playoffs have been
going on so she made your list that's
right
she did not Mike she got the proverbial
snow okay unfortunately I mentioned
that's all what has she been doing in in
hockey rinks duh he's been having
concerts oh the ones that she was
usually in ahead of us or I just didn't
know oh I just didn't know if she was
like the first star of the game Mike
suited up in play
Reggie Jackson has been in one of the
arenas in San Jose we've had a lot of
stars hanging around in these various
places but no not shares he did not
attend a game well Jon Hamm Jon it's
great to talk to you too Jon Hamm has
been front and center in st. Louis and
is truly given a face and a voice
obviously to a bunch of Blues fans that
have been waiting waiting waiting for
moments like obviously Game two but more
in particular game four where they could
personally eyeball what is going on with
the Pat mahomes was there in Jenna
Fischer just again people were just
giving voice to the st. Louis what was
it like to witness that moment there it
was it was fun being a part of it it's
always fun to be a part of an exciting
event like this but I think also to see
our game is a collision game man I've
talked to NFL players who marvel at the
fact that these guys can play four of
these in a week's time and it was
another one of those ultimate collision
games that had a lot of chaos built into
it but at the end there are a lot of
times that you can't improve on anything
with words and so for the last 15
seconds or so I just said nothing
because we don't need crowd Mike's in a
place like st. Louis you just let the
crowd dictate what's going on and the
crowd just yelled itself hoarse and
that's time they'd ever won a Stanley
Cup final game in their own City and so
we let them have it
and we let the organist play the st.
Louis Blues
and we let the horn sound and people
gather around the goaltender and let the
pictures tell the story it was an
exciting atmosphere just like Boston
will be because it always is when they
pass the banner around they've had Bill
Belichick there to wave the banner
they've had Bobby Orr to do it too
I don't know who they're gonna come up
with tomorrow night but it'll be fun to
find out yeah I know it has been just an
exciting playoff as always and then this
series what what are you hearing at all
about Chara and his broken jaw and what
you think is so important for him to be
out there on the ice on Thursday night
doc we have not heard anything yet today
one heartening thing is that mat grizzly
who was wounded by the suspension
bringing a check from Oscar Sun Quest
did take part and a non-contact Jerseyan
was part of the practice on the second
power play unit so that was a harking
thing in that there may be a possibility
there but they're holding off any
announcement at least so far on what
charas possibility can be he's the
inspirational guy on that team and even
though he did not participate in the
fourth and clinching game down in
Raleigh he was the first guy out on the
ice at the horn and rallied around the
team and was the leader in the handshake
line after these are rallying things
that are so much part of Stanley Cup
lore and I'm sure it's the same in other
sports so I've not been around them so
closely as I have hockey rich but these
are the emotional bonds that teams form
as they get to a final after they've
gone through six weeks of all of this
punishment and so you know that he
didn't have any there there was no
reason that he could play in the third
period of the fourth game but he wanted
to be there for his team and at one
point he went up and down the bench
encouraging his team as best he could
and with their with the injury he had I
don't know how he couldn't do a lot of
courage and talk but he did his best and
that's what you see much of it this time
of year
six-time Emmy Award winner doc Emmerich
here in the Honda inside a report
getting set to call Game five
on NBC tomorrow night in Boston where
does the Blues story rank for you doc I
mean a team that was in literally dead
last a few days into our calendar year
in 2019 turning to a young goaltender
Catching Fire playing Laura Branigan is
Gloria based on them drinking in
Philadelphia one night before that
everything started and and and watching
a bar breakout in that song and that
becomes their their rallying cry an
interesting choice of song but all
together they go from dead last now to
two wins away from hoisting the cup for
a city that's been dying to see it for
the first time where does that all rank
for you well in the 46 years I've been
around this it's right now it's in the
top 10 all-time and the stories that I
could possibly tell about a run and it
would be top five if not at the very top
if they pull it off because you just
don't have that many rags to riches
finishes the Minnesota North Stars in
1991 were were a story that was similar
to that in that they they upset so many
teams including Chicago which had won
the Presidents Trophy and then st. Louis
and then the defending champion Oilers
to get to the final before they got
pretty well taken into camp by the
Pittsburgh Penguins but this is one if
they pull it off it'll be an ultimate
story and a Cinderella story to write
forever we had one of those last year
and it would have been an even greater
story of Vegas would have been able to
win the championship but it turned out
to be a magnificent story regardless
just because of all that Vegas came
through we're just fortunate that we get
stories like this seemingly every season
in hockey and occasionally it's a story
that gets written right into the Stanley
Cup final and that's what we've got this
year have you ever drank out of the cup
doc no no I never have I've always been
sort of a neutral party watching other
people celebrate it before but no I've
never had that opportunity when I was in
Portland Maine in the American League we
had a group of guys that were
Philadelphia Flyers farm team in the
seven
and of course the Flyers were very well
known in the 70s they won two Stanley
Cups themselves and they they tailored
their team in Portland to be very much
like the Flyers team in Philadelphia was
in that they had plenty of scrappers and
plenty of scores and so we won two
consecutive championships in Portland
the Calder Cup was much smaller but it
had a bowl that held lots of champagne
and the players held it for me to drink
champagne from then but no ever since so
is it a professionalism thing that you
would that you have not done it is it
just you it's not been offered to you
and I'm always with a neutral party you
know they're not a part of a team
anymore and so so no I've never wind up
down first of all the dressing room is
is so jammed with people that would not
be a party I'd be invited to to begin
with because they they've had people
that have weathered the storm all year
to be with them
and and secondly I guess secondly is the
first one it's just not a party I'm
invited to but I sure enjoy watching
people celebrate okay I understand that
but I would love to just see that that
photograph one day for you well I don't
know that it'll ever happen but the one
thing's for sure the people that that
have it I remember Alexander Ovechkin
celebration last year right I don't know
that anyone's ever enjoyed it more than
he did because he had suffered so long I
think it's still going actually doc I
don't know we've checked on him at any
point in time but it might actually
still be going so well if in it if that
celebration ever happens I will get a
picture and I will send it to you okay
I'd love that I would love that so I
will take that so what what is the key
do you think over the next obviously
game five but potentially over the next
three games and if we were so blessed by
Game seven for you to call on NBC what
what do you think is the key here to
lifting the cup for either team
the strangest thing and it's it's so
trite but the the team that gets to do
what it wants to do and we've had two
games of both teams getting to do what
they wanted to do with the Blues it's
being disciplined and and applying
therefore check which they were able to
do effectively twice and they lost their
discipline a couple of times and for the
Bruins it's getting to do what they want
to do and apply their game which is
rushing five men at a time and using
their power play and each of these games
has taken on a different life of its own
and just about the time you think
someone has momentum they don't and so
each game is its own entity and that's
why game 5 is going to be so exciting
and if you think that whoever wins game
5 has got the leg up on game six I think
you're going to be dead wrong so I think
we're going seven that'll be great that
would just be awesome last one for you
doc is one of the most one of the more
moving moments that I've witnessed was
you winning you're a me a couple of
years ago one of them and you gave out
your email address for young kids to
reach out to you if they want to get
into play-by-play you did it again this
past year have you received any emails
has anybody actually taken you up on
that oh yes and you know what happens is
and they do it and I you know I I
encourage them to because it's a great
business to be and isn't it rich I mean
you go to play every day and if you're
doing play-by-play you get a great seat
for the game you get in free and you get
to work with wonderful people and and
you get to be around these athletes and
I found the hockey guys just to be
magnificent but also it winds up being a
great living whether you're working in a
in a small community where you're a very
important part of the community or
whether you get to do national games
it's a great living and yes I have heard
from from a number of aspiring
broadcasters and and I've actually asked
a couple of them to resend all of the
material that they sent because it does
take up a good deal of memory and I
don't
get to do these until August by then the
free agency period is over the draft is
over and all of the things that take up
a lot of memory I have been deleted and
now I've got time to really sort through
and give the proper time to listening to
them and their some of them are really
good and some of them I have some
suggestions for and then I hear back
from them and one last thing I am very
pleased not that I had anything to do
with it
that Jack Michael the announcer in
Edmonton and John Walton the announcer
in Washington both years ago sent me
some of their material from the minor
leagues and now they're not sending
material out anymore because they made
it they have made it and I'll tell you
doc just before I let you go here I was
fortunate to call my first NFL game for
the NFL Network last year in London and
I've been very fortunate again to do
what I do for a living I can't remember
as much fun as I've had on the job just
describing action and going with the
flow and and and figuring out when to
shut up
and let the crowd tell the story as you
as you mentioned before your decision to
make at the end of Game four with st.
Louis fans celebrating their first ever
home Stanley Cup win it's an endeavor
that is so rewarding and in watching
somebody like you make it look so easy
it's just amazing it really is thank you
for saying that Richard it's a great
observation you had even at the end of a
game like you had there and London and
just multiply that times having done a
hundred of those you can imagine the
adrenaline rush that somebody like
myself still gets from years of doing
that but but I hope you get a chance to
do another thousand of those because it
is fun and one thing that a guy named
Bill Clemente taught me years ago and I
was working at ESPN he and I were doing
national games together and one of his
advices to me was don't bring the game
in your briefcase what you know have
have all of your preparation done but
don't try to force things in because it
don't sound
first and the athletes are human beings
and they're going to deliver you a game
and be ready to adjust to whatever you
might have in your mind but don't force
it because you may you may be way off
track if you try to jam something in and
I've always tried to remember that
Billie gave me lots of great advice and
he and I used to do a training camp
together when the players weren't there
was we would practice doing interviews
practice working in front of a mirror
and I always thought that was a great
thing to do he was very influential in
any success that I had well doc look
forward to Game five Thursday night and
more and it's always a pleasure for me
to have you calling into the show so
thanks for doing that okay rich thank
you it's great to talk to you you bet
that's Mike doc Emmerich NBC Sports
calling him from Boston for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under rec TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app